ليست اول وفاه لسجين من معارضي النظام
المصري وعلى الارجح جدا لن تكون الاخيره
لم ينجو احمد عبد ربو من غول الاهمال
الطبي داخل السجون الم المصريه وانضم الى
قائمه بعشرات المعارضين الذين قضوا بفعل
ما تصفه منظمات حقوقيه دوليه ومحليه
بسياسه الموت البطيء التي تمارسها السلطات
المصريه بحق معارضيها سلطات تنفي ان تكون
قد اضطهدت اي معتقل لديها معتبره ان مشكله
اولئك السجناء المعارضين ليست معها وانما
مع قوانين الدوله المصريه وهي واجبه
الانفاذ في كل الاحوال حتى لو كان الحال
هو تفشي فيروس كورونا وتعالي الاصوات
الداعيه لانقاذ المسجونين من مخاطر الموت
به تلك التي تضاف لمعاناتهم جراء انتهاك
ممنهج لحرمه اجسادهم وحقوقهم الانسانيه
تقرير مريم اوباييش نبدا بعده
النقاش الموت غير الرحيم في سجون مصر
محظور الحدث عنه في وسائل الاعلام الرسميه
وويل لمن يتطرق او يشير للموضوع على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي بالنفي او التجاهل
تتعاطى السلطات مع انباء المعتقلين
السياسيين الذين خرجوا من معتقلات جثثا مع
تصريح بالدفن في غياب تصاريح الزيارات
للاحياء والمرضى منذ شهور والمصدر الوحيد
لما يحدث في السجون السيئه السمعه مثل
العقرب وطر اخبار تسرب لاهالي المعتقلين
ومنظمات حقوقيه محليه ودوليه عن طريقها
اعلن نباء وفاه السياسي احمد عبد ربو بسبب
الاهمال الطبي في سجن العقرب كان معتقلا
منذ عامين ليرتفع عدد من فارقوا الحياه
منذ يناير العام الجاري بسبب غياب ادنى
الشروط الصحيه في السجون الى
57 يصف المنتقدون للنظام الحالي السجون
المصريه بالمقابر الجماعيه الوضع فيها سيء
قبل كورونا وما بعدها اسوا واقصى على
المعتقلين وذويهم الذين حرموا من ال
وادخال الادويه وبعض الطعام الصحي منذ
بدايه تفشي الجائحه دقت هيومان رايتس وتش
نقوس الخطر وحذرت السلطات المتهمه بانتهاك
حقوق الانسان وقمع الحريات واعتقال
المعارضين دون محكمات نزيهه وعادله من
تفشي الفيروس القاتل والمعدي في السجون
واقسام الشرطه ما كان محتملا في بدايه
الجائحه بت حقيقه مؤلمه للاهالي اصيب مئات
المعتقلين وتوفي في عدد منهم بعد اصابتهم
بالفيروس تكتظ السجون بالمعتقلين وتفتقر
للتهويه المناسبه والاجراءات الاحترازيه
التي ناشدت منظمات حقوقيه القاهره اتخاذها
وفق اهالي السجناء لم ينقل المصابون
بكورونا الى المستشفيات المختصه ولم تقدم
لهم الرعايه الطبيه اللازمه كما لم يخضع
المخالطون للعزل او اجراءات التباعد
الاجتماعي دعوه الافراج عن المعتقل لنا
السياسيين منذ بدايه الجائحه قبلت بالرفض
والتجاهل من قبل نظام مصري يرد في كل مره
بان كل السجناء يعاملون وفق القانون
ومعايير حقوق الانسان وينعمون بالرعايه
الصحيه اللازمه اين النيابه العامه
المسؤوله عن السجون يستغيث اهالي من ماتوا
او من المحتمل ان يفارقوا الحياه بسبب
الاهمال في اي لحظه في بلد قطاعه الصحي
اصلا عليل يمكن تخيل الوضع داخل زنازين
السجون واقسام الشرطه تقول منظمات حقوقيه
مصير الاف السجناء في خطر محدق داخل بلد
النقد فيه جريمه يعاقب عليها قانون النظام
الحالي مع استمرار عدم استجابه القاهره
لدعوات المنظمات الحقوقيه يرتفع عدد
النعوش التي تخرج من المعتقلات الموبوءه
بكورونا وانتهاكات حقوق الانسان معتقلات
مصر قصص مروعه قد تروى
يوما لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القاهره عبر سكايب الباحث والمحلل السياسي
احمد العناني ومن اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي
المصري جمال سلطان ومن مشيغن عبر سكايب
ادم شابيرو مسؤول الحملات في منظمه فرونت
لاين ديفندرز اهلا بكم ضيوفنا ابدا معك من
القاهره سيد احمد العناني وتتوالى الوفيات
بين المعتقلين في السجون المصريه لماذا
برايك
يعني اولا لا يوجد معتقلين سياسيين في مصر
حضر يعني تفضلت يعني ببدايه حديثك بكلمه
معتقلين لا يوجد معتقدين في الداخل المصري
هناك احكام هناك قضايا هناك يعني قضايا
يعني يحقق فيها هناك احكام نهائيه يعني
هناك من يعني هناك كانت صدرت ضده احكام
نهائيه وهناك في واقع الامر من يتم
التحقيق معه في بعض القضايا وبالتالي على
ما اعتقد من وجهه نظري انا مفد حققت يعني
قا تم كبير في ملف حقوق الانسان منذ يعني
2013 و 30 من يونيو والحقيقه ده مش بشهاده
يعني بشهاده المنظمات الحقوقيه حتى يعني
مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع للامم المتحده
كانت هناك توصيات منذ 2013 وهناك تقدم
كبير بصفه عامه اعتقد انه تسييس الموضوع
من بعض المنظمات المحسوبه على جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين ودعينا نتحدث وبكل صراحه
حينما يعني يتوفى احد من جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين يعني وفاه طبيعيه ص النهارده
الدنيا يعني طيب جميل الوضع اذا جيد في
سجون المصريه سيد احمد العناني انت تقول
لا يوجد معتقلون سياسيون في مصر في الوقت
الذي تتحدث فيه منظمات حقوقيه عن وجود
اكثر من 60 ال معتقل نتحول الى السيد ادم
شابيرو ضيفنا من القاهره يعني لا يتحدث
فقط عن اسباب الوفيات داخل السجون هو ينفي
تماما وجود المعتقلين السياسيين كيف ترى
هذا
الكلام سيد
ادم طبعا
بكل الصدق اقول هذه
ادعاءات السخيفه تنافي المنطق طبعا القول
بانه ليس هناك معتقلين لكن هناك معتقلون
ينتظرون المحاكمه الكل يعرف الاوضاع
زميلكم في الجزيره خير شاهد على ذلك هم
طبعا دائما يقولون ان يقولون هذا الكلام
السخيف بان هذه ادعاءات من منظمات حقوق
الانسان ظروف السجن ليست من النوع الذي
يؤدي الىي انسان يعيش ظروفا طبيعيه صحيا
وخاصه في ظروف انتشار
الكورونا كما ان اعداد الوفيات في السجون
بسبب عدم
تلقيهم العنايه الطبيه طبعا هناك اناس
ماتوا بسبب حالات مرضيه معروفه ورغم
المناشدات بضروره رعايتهم الطبيه التي لم
يحصلوا عليها
ايضا مصطفى القبرين الذي هو عضم 6 ابريل
وغيره
ايضا هناك
اتهامات منافيه للمنطق تماما بحق هؤلاء
دائما تستخدم ادعاءات تهديدهم للامن اللي
يعتقلوا لا اعتقد اننا يجب ان نعطي الكثير
من المصداقيه لمثل هذه الادعاءات النافيه
ل الوضع سيد جمال سلطان السلطات المصريه
تقول نوفر كل الرعايه لكافه السج نا داخل
اقسام الشرطه المصريه وبالتالي برايك ما
سبب توالي الوفيات التي نسمع عنها تقريبا
يوميا داخل
السجون المصريه منذ بدايه هذه
السنه لا هي الحقيقه المساله لا تحتاج الى
لا تحتمل الكثير من من من الجدل والكثير
من المراوغه المساله يعني تتصل مباشره بال
الاهمال الطبي الجسيم انه فوضه يعني اذا
كان المواطن المصري العادي الذي يعيش خارج
السجون يعاني من الاهمال الطبي واللام
مبالا و وتدني وتدهور البنيه الاساسيه
للصحه في عموم مصر المواطن العادي اللي هو
مش سجين فكيف
تتصور كيف يكون حال السجين ثم توالي هذه
الوفيات بشكل غريب جدا جدا عشرات الوفيات
من هؤلاء وكثير منهم من الشباب اللي هو
صغير السن وسواء يتوفى بكورونا او بغير
كورونا فالحقيقه هذه المساله يعني واضحه
ان المساله هي تتعلق
ب الاهمال الطبي المشكله هنا مش ليست في
تصنيف الم الامر انه اهمال طبي او غير
اهمال طبي هو اهمال طبي قطعا قولا واحدا
لكن المساله هل هو مساله متعمده هل هو
اهمال متعمد انا في تقديري ان هذا الاهمال
متعمد
لانه يعني باي حساب باي حساب سياسي باي
منطق سياسي اي نظام حكم يوجه له تهمه قتل
المعارضين قتلا بطيئا داخل السجون هذه
مساله تحدث انتفاضه كبيره تعمد سيد جمال
لماذا يكون هناك تعمد لحدوث هذه الوفيات
داخل السجون المصريه الا يضر ذلك النظام
اكثر مما يستفيد منهم داخل السجون
وبالتالي ليس لهم اي
تاثير هو السياسه التي ينتهجها النظام
الحالي على مدار سبع سنوات منذ
مقدمي هي سياسه اثاره اكبر اقصى قدر من
الرعب واقصى قدر من العنف الذي يربك
المعارض او يروع المعارض او يروع المواطن
عن اي تفكير في المعارضه يعني لم تشهد مصر
ابدا في تاريخها ان تحدث مذبحه على ايدي
قوات رسميه من من متظاهرين او من معتصمين
في
ميادين في يوم واحد وقبلها بايام 60 واحد
وقبلها بايام 70 واحد وربما في اقل من
اربعه طيب في اقل من 48 ساعه فقط وفي
اربعه معتقلين في مناطق مختلفه او في سجون
مختلفه نتحدث عن احمد عبد ربو نتحدث عبد
الرحمن زوال وقبل ذلك كذلك عصام العريان و
غيرهم كثيرون سيد احمد العلاني هل يعقل ان
يكون هؤلاء كلهم توفوا بشكل
طبيعي يعني بدايه ما جاء حديث ضيفي في ق
الامر ينافي تماما للحقيقه يعني بعيدا
تماما ملي بالمغالطات وبعيدا تماما عن
المصداقيه تتحدث عن وفيات وفيات طبيعيه
يعني يعني هناخذ مثال محمد مرسي حينما
اخشي عليه داخل قفص الاتهاب خرج جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين تقول لك النظام في مصر
الحقيقه قتل محمد مرسي فح محمد مرسي اخشي
عليه ان امام امام القاضي وا اذا كانت
وفاه طبيعيه لماذا لم يسمح بالتحقيق في
الامر اذا كانت وفاه طبيعيه لماذا التكتم
من قبل السلطات المصريه تم التحقيق في
الامر يا سيده الفضل تم التحقيق في الامر
من قبل وسع يعني اداره السجون النيابه
العامه وطب الشارع وقال ان الفاء وفاء
طبيعيه عصام العريان وفاء طبيعيه انما
حينما يعني يتوفى او يموت حد من جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين تقعد الدنيا ولم تقعد في
حين ان هناك وصات حتى من المساجين
العاديين هناك وطيات هذا يعني يعني قضاء
وقضا النهارده
يعني السجين داخل الحقيقه السجون المصريه
يتمتع بالحق في العلاج يتمتع في حقق
بالتريض له كف زيارات الحق مكوله وممنوعه
لحقيقه شاهدنا الصور احمد سيد احمد شاهدنا
الصور المسربه من داخل السجون المصريه
اوضاع كارثيه غير انسانيه عكس تماما
الصوره التي تحاول السلطات المصريه نقلها
من خلال تقارير اعلاميه منظمه تظهر
المسجونين وانهم يعيشون حياه جميله داخل
السجون وياكلون اللحوم
والخضروات يعني قبل ما ارد على حضرتك يعني
الاستاذ اسطنبول عن المجازر مجازر ايه
تتحدث عن الربعه والنهضه تتحدث الحقيقه عن
يعني سحات كانت ي بالجماعات
الؤال الدقائق القليله التي
بق ترفع السلاح في وجه الدوله
نتحدث اله هذه الجماعات الحقيقه ان يكون
ان يكون
هناك تخرج من هذه الحقيقه استح وكن
الحقيقه جماعه الارهاب اصره وجماعه الاخو
اتحدث عن السجون المصريه وليس عن جماعه
الاخوان ارجوك
جاوبني
يعني الحالات الوفيات المتكرره هي حالات
وفاه طبيعيه يعني لا يوجد حاله وفاء يعني
فليات احد الحقيقه النهارده بدليل مادي
يقول ان النظام النهارده يعني يقصر حاله
وفاه طبيعيه ارجوك يعني عبد الرحمن زوال
مثلا 39 سنه تم اعتقاله قبل ست سنوات
المنظمات الحقوقيه وصفت ظروف اعتقاله
بالسيئه جدا كيف تفسر ذلك 39 سنه كيف يموت
وفاه
طبيعيه يعني سيئه جدا عشان هو محسوب على
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين لم يخن محسوب على
اي تيار
سياسي اصبح يعني المت طبيعيه انما اذا
اصبح من جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين امر لا يصدق تماما مفهوم سيد ادم
شبير واذا كانت التقارير الحقوقيه تؤكد
وجود اكثر من 60 الف معتقل منذ طاح بال
الرئيس المصري محمد مرسي وظروف اعتقال
سيئه جدا اذا كان النظام المصريين في وجود
كل هؤلاء كيف له او نتوقع منه ان يؤكد ما
ياتي في التقارير الحقوقيه عن ان الظروف
سيئه في
السجون اعتقد انكم تستمعون هذه ل كيف ان
النظام يتعامل مع تقاريرنا ومع المعلومات
الموثقه وذات المصداقيه التي نقدمها من
خلال ضيفكم من القاهره بالقول بان كل
هؤلاء يموتون من اسباب وفاه
طبيعيه طبعا
اذا هم يجعلون ان الموت في السجن هو سبب
الوفاه الطبيعيه فقط لكنهم طبعا هم يعتبر
السجين عدو للدوله ايا كان السبب ربما
لانتقاد حقوق الانسان فهذا من الطبيعي في
رايهم ان يؤدي الى وفاه طبيعيه كما
يسمونها في مصر
طبعا هذه المحاج تنافي المنطق وهي سخيفه
نحن نعرف ان المسجونين يموتون في السجن
ونعلم ان هناك 60 ال منهم على الاق
والحكه نفسها من السيسي الى الحكم بنت 26
سجنا لاحتواء كل هؤلاء و طبعا النظام
سيستمر في عرض اشرطه فيديو جميله تبين ان
حياتهم في نعيم طيب سيد جمال سيد جمال
اتحول اليك سريعا لماذا كل هذه الانتقادات
الى النظام المصري فحتى خارج السجون هناك
من يموت فيروس كورونا كذا لك يفتك
بالكثيرين داخل السجون وخارجها وفي العالم
كله لماذا اذا انتقاد النظام
المصري لا شوفي هو هناك فيديو مشهور على
على شبكه الانترنت الان في حوار في قناه
مصريه من
القاهره يتحدث فيها احد قيادات الداخليه
يعني في في
فتره الحيويه التي كانت فيها مصر ايام
ثوره يناير هو يتكلم بوضوح كان هو مدير
سجن العقرب هو واللواء هذا مدير سجن
العقرب يقول ان هذا السجن مصمم بحيث ان من
يدخله حيا لا يخرج منه حيا هذا هذا مدير
سجن العقرب الحقيقه انه في يعني قطعا لهذا
الجدل
ووشوشه نعتبرها
التي تقوم بها المنظمات الحقوقيه الدوليه
انا اعتقد انه المبدا الذي
ارساها النائب العام والنيابه العامه
المصريه في قضيه جوليو ريجيني اعتقد انه
يمكن تطبيقه على كثير من هذه الحالات بان
يكون هناك شراكه دوليه في التحقيقات وفي
الرقابه وفي معرفه تح يعني لا احد يعني
هناك اتهامات الانان الدكتور محمد مرسي
الرئيس رئيس الجمهوريه السابق لم يمت وفه
طبيعيه من يعرف من يستطيع ان يجزم بذلك
وفي دقيقه فقط احمد العناني يعني هناك
شكوك اتهامات كثيره موجهه للنظام المصري
لماذا لا يكون شفاف وصريح ويفتح السجون
لتحقيق
شفاف يعني الحقيقه الدوله المصريه وبتحديد
الداخليه المصريه والمؤسسات الدوليه
المؤسسات المصريه تقوم يعني الحقيقه بفتح
يعني السجون لكافه الحقيقه المؤسسات وجميع
الحقيقه المؤسسات العامله في حقوق الانسان
حتى المؤسسات الدوليه احنا ما عندناش حاجه
نخبيها الدوله المصريه ليس لديها ما تخفيه
فيما يخص الوضع في السجون السجين داخل بعد
اذن حضرتك
استجين والمحلل السياسي من القاهره اعتذر
منك بشده انتهى وقت الحصاد من اسطنبول
كاتب الصحفي المصري جمال السلطان ومن
مشيغن عبر سكايب ادم شبير مسؤول الحملات
في منظمه فرونت لاين ديفندرز الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء